welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
welcome listening friends would you like
to hear an amazing fact the world's
oldest person and last known to have
been born in the 1800s died April 15
2017 Associated Press reported Emma
Morano
a hundred and seventeen years old of
Italy died tranquilly Saturday afternoon
while sitting in a rocking chair in her
home located in the northern town near
Vera bina born on November 29th 1899
morano's life spanned three centuries
she was believed to be the last
surviving person born in the 1800s
Murano was the oldest of eight children
her siblings and one child all preceded
her in death including his sister who
lived to be a hundred and two she worked
in a twine factory and at a boarding
school kitchen and retired at 75 more
than 40 years ago ping can you imagine
that retired at 75 40 years ago when
asked if she had any secrets for a long
life and they explained she ate simple
food did not overeat and got plenty of
rest she went to bed early sleeping at
least 10 hours every night her friends
say she also had very good genetics you
know doctors say the three most
important things you can do to lengthen
your life is eat natural food get plenty
of exercise and choose your ancestors
very carefully did you know the Bible
says having the right ancestors can
actually lengthen your life stay with
his friends we're gonna learn more as
amazing facts brings you this edition of
Bible answers live
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
our phone lines are now open if you have
a Bible related question call us at one
eight hundred
that's one eight hundred four sixty
three seventy to ninety seven now let's
join our host pastor Doug Batchelor and
our co-host pastors Jean Ross
welcome listening friends to Bible
answers live and we are live this easter
day if you have a Bible question we
invite you to give us a call that number
800 four six three seven two nine seven
if you'd like the acronym it's eight
hundred God says because we find out
what God says in his word to get our
answers one more time maybe two more
times eight hundred four six three seven
two nine seven or I could say it this
way eight hundred four sixty three
seventy to ninety seven if you have a
Bible question give us a call we have
lines wide open here on the studio we'd
like to find out what are your Bible
questions my name is Doug Batchelor
my name is John Ross good evening
listening friends and past Doug once
again let's begin the program with the
word of Prayer dear father thank you
that we have this opportunity to take a
few moments here at the beginning of a
new week to spend time studying your
word and we ask for your blessing to be
with us Lord goddess and a clear
understanding of Bible truth for we
asked us in Jesus name Amen
amen oh pastor day you spoke about this
individual who lived what a hundred and
seventeen years born back in 1899 you
know when you're reading that fact to
reminded me several years ago now I had
a church member who was born back in the
1800s eighteen somewhere in 98 I think
and she's in a nursing home I'd go visit
her and she would tell me stories how
that her father was captured by Native
Americans in North Dakota and how that
the cavalry had come in to rescue him
and I just said listening she was really
sharp and and just had all this history
I know these stories I had a I had a
church member that could go back and
tell you about you know when Teddy
Roosevelt was president and and it was
pretty amazing listening I don't
remember that would talk about World War
one and the battles in the world when it
just some of those folks said they had
incredible history like my grandfather
lived through World War one and two and
he just lived through a very interesting
time of history and and but this lady is
one of the last ones or they think the
last they know of that her life actually
spanned over the 1800s she covered the
1900s and made it to 2000 and 2017 but
to that is quite remarkable her friends
say of course you know her her simple
lifestyle staying active and in the
exercise simple diet not overeating
plenty of rest those are all very
important and you are born with a
certain amount a disposition sort of
genetic factors that can give you better
odds I mean many of us remember George
Burns who lived to about a hundred but
he always had a drink in one hand and a
cigar in the other
and he'd sell well you know it's not
gonna hurt me but I think well he would
have lived 115 if he hadn't done this
thing
she just had good genes but the Bible
actually says that who you're related to
can make a difference in eternal life
first of all when you study the
genealogies in the Bible you do see
certain families did live longer because
many of them it gives their lifespans
like you look at the tribe of Levi and
Levi lived a very long time as did his
descendants Amram and jock Abed and then
Moses Aaron and Miriam all three lived
over 120 years and so they had some
pretty good genes but and of course they
tell you you know some people have a you
can get a DNA test now and it'll tell
you if you've got genetic markers that
you got a better chance of outliving
heart disease or whatever it is but in
the Bible when you become a Christian
you are adopted into the family of God
and those genes the DNA of Jesus gives
you everlasting life that's a life I
want this body you do your best to take
care of it and that's important but it's
not gonna last forever but if you have
everlasting life that's the life that
never ends a life that is eternal that
can be measured with a life of god
there's a verse
first John 5:12 he that has the son has
life he that doesn't have the son does
not have life so friends do you have the
son of God have you been adopted have
you accepted Jesus and you don't need to
be afraid of death because you'll be in
that resurrection of the righteous or if
you're alive when Christ comes you'll be
transformed and given a glorified body
maybe you'd like to know how to get your
your genes repaired and then all you've
got to do is call and we'll send you a
free book on the steps to heaven the
book is called three steps to heaven and
it's a free offer this evening if you'd
like to receive it just give us a call
on our resource phone number and that
number is 885 six seven four seven and
again you can ask for the book called
three steps to heaven
that number is 888-259-3826 unday so my
question is which of which of your
points would you begin with well I just
first of all I try and get them to agree
that it doesn't make a difference which
day we keep his holy and God of course
in the Ten Commandments is extremely
definitive he says
these seventh day remember these things
remember a seventh day and so when we
make that clear to them that they're to
remember a particular day and then he
tells them what that day was and then
there are even people who are punished
for not observing that day it's
obviously important to God and so if we
show that hasn't changed there's nothing
in history that shows it has changed
then you have to ask yourself the
question does God still want people to
keep the Ten Commandments including that
one commandment actually commandment
number four but that one commandment
that says remember the Sabbath day so
you know I'd start there and just get
agreement on that okay all right and
then I was also going to go back to
being a memorial of creation in Ezekiel
it says that it you know it it's not
only a memorial creation but it's a
memorial of sanctification God made the
day holy it also tells us he can make us
holy and so we all still believe that
God is our Creator we believe that God
is our Sanctifier and every Sabbath
we're remembering that he can recreate
us and he can sing defy us
okay okay so the point about constantine
changing it would that be an early point
to bring up or further if they're
wanting to know the history of you know
why why do so many Christians observe
the first day as opposed to the day that
that Jesus kept and you can say well it
didn't happen overnight you explained
over a period of three hundred years it
gradually changed several factors happen
together chantal you know one was the
Jews became very unpopular in Rome when
they rebelled about 70 80 68 AD and
their religion was forbidden well there
are so many similarities between the
Christians and the Jews they used the
same book the Bible and they you know
had a lot of the same laws and of course
the Christianity is rooted in the Bible
and Judaism
that Christians wanted to distance
themselves from the Jews and so for a
while they began to keep two days
gradually they gave up the seventh
seventh day in preference for the more
popular Roman day but this demonstrate
that in history and I'll definitely be
sure to tell them about no Sabbath truth
is a great website has some good history
good resources okay so other than that
during the conversation do I just let
them kind of lead with their questions
just you know whatever point they make
just just go go in that direction and
pray and see you know how the Holy
Spirit might guide and yet you you know
you've tried to basically scratch where
a person's hitching in and if they're
interested in the history you share the
history there under what those spiritual
reasons are you share those and and pray
the Holy Spirit Guides yeah that's
really a huge part of it
historical change that's really how you
know I went off in a different direction
that's a huge part of it yeah and then
you know you can always ask a person if
a person is a good Bible Christian you
say alright show me the commandment to
keep the first day holy now I know what
I'm saying is almost an Emma today
because it's Easter in many ways and we
believe in this you know we believe that
Jesus rose Sunday we have no problem
with that of course but nowhere in any
of the events around that weekend did
Christ say now this is the new Sabbath
yes it's very important and it's gonna
take an extremely important event at his
birth
everything all three births death and
resurrection really all three go
together but it doesn't make it
substitute exactly absolutely okay all
right hey thank you very much Chantal
appreciate your question and for our
listeners that opens up a line we still
have lines open if you have a Bible
question we're gonna be here another
fifty minutes answering questions the
number 800 god says eight hundred four
six three seven two nine seven anacs
holy zamalek listening from Orlando
Florida Malik
welcome to the program thank you very
much my question today is if the Messiah
was the only begotten Son of God
yeah and when they go through his
Messiah lineage why isn't God in either
Mary or Joseph lineage in the Bible well
I I would respectfully disagree I think
that Jesus is if you look in the Book of
Luke where it talks about the genealogy
of Jesus and Luke chapter 3 it said Seth
who is the son of Adam who is the son of
God and so you even find the phrase Adam
being a son of God in the genealogy of
Jesus so is that what you're talking
about
no I'm not sure what chapter Luke
chapter 3 what it's like I guess when it
goes through Mary and Joseph yeah well
you find the lineage of Mary I know I'm
sorry the lineage of Joseph is in
Matthew is that right pastor Ross and
the lineage of Joseph's father in law
which would be Mary's father is in Luke
so Luke traces it through Mary's side
Joseph traces it through Matthew's um
I'm sorry I'm Matthew G traces it
through Joseph's side so you've got both
in the Bible but they both go back to
seven chapters correct yes Matthew
chapter one first chapter in the New
Testament is a genealogy the traces from
Joseph's back - I think at least King
David goes all the way up to Abraham
Abraham okay that's right yeah I should
have wrote it down with why I called
there's a specific chapter where it
shows the lineage of Jesus Mary and
Joseph in the same exact chapter and God
name there's no way in there so more
like you next time I call I'll
definitely have that for you guys and
you just look at that particular chapter
but
so I read it it does not have God's name
in there like he's saying he's but I
guess that's a different place but I
guess my thing is when that's like time
comes to on the context of something
from what my understanding when I was
took English to convey the context of
that what I'm speaking about should be
somewhere within that arm exact since
it's like a whole bunch of sentence
before happiness should be somewhere
combined here so I guess I'm just trying
to find that context that's what I'm I
guess what I'm asking
so do you have a or do you have a
problem or you take issue with the idea
that Jesus is the Son of God you don't
believe that well if you're if you're
gonna go by the Bible and so you're
asking that's a question about the Bible
when the angel appeared to her the angel
actually says that the Holy Child that
she would have because he's conceived by
the Holy Spirit would be the son of God
so it's in context I know I'm sorry no I
just can say it is in the context of the
the story the biblical account of Mary's
pregnancy that Jesus would be called the
Son of God because she was inseminated
by the Holy Spirit according to the
Bible for lack of a better term I got
you but I know in Jeremiah 31 9 is
Israel and if when is my firstborn right
so they're saying that's another verse
that's another verse in the Bible is
saying this is God's firstborn Oh though
I'm glad you asked that you know the the
answer I'd have for that is you go back
all the way to exercise you're onto
something interesting there is when the
Lord brought the children of Israel out
of Egypt God called Israel the whole
nation his firstborn as a nation not any
one person so when God talks about
Israel and our Judah and Ephraim he's
talking about the the northern and
southern
kingdoms of Israel they are his
firstborn because God chose a nation
when he chose Israel he said this is
like my firstborn nation it's not not
saying that Jesus can't be the firstborn
because he uses the metaphor of the
nation being a firstborn and that's why
God slew all of the firstborn in Egypt
he said if you're not gonna let my
firstborn go I will punish your
firstborn and that angel of death went
through during the Passover and all the
firstborn of Egypt died in the houses
that did not have the blood over the
door hey Malik I appreciate your
question hope that helps a little bit
and when we might have to have a longer
conversation because it sounds like
you're you're searching but we're gonna
take another call so well pastor Ross
who do we have lined up we've got
Carolyn listening in Minnesota
Carolyn welcome to the program my
question is tonight how often did they
do this sin offering
well the temple they had a daily sin
offering that was to for the nation the
priests would offer they had the morning
and the evening sacrifice then they had
special offerings during the feasts
among the seven Jewish feasts there were
three of the seven and pastor Ross jump
in if I get this wrong but I'm just
going from memory
three of the seven feasts the men would
go up to Jerusalem there was an assembly
they could bring their families but the
men were required to come Jesus went to
his first Passover when he was 12 and
they would have special offerings there
but throughout the course of the year
any family leader could go and make a
sacrifice for his family and they didn't
do it on a daily basis I mean you think
every time we sin or do something wrong
we'd be killing lambs all day long
that's not what they did back then
but when there was something particular
otherwise those offerings were covered
during the annual feasts men could not
afford to be going to the temple
you know once a week to offer sacrifice
so how did they determine when they were
going there - well it was usually
predetermined by the three annual feasts
and they would sacrifice then for the
sins of the past of course the big one
was Yom Kippur or the Day of Atonement
where they were all the nation's sins
that had accumulated through the past
year were covered during that ceremony
and also the son offering that was often
in the sanctuary in the morning in the
evening there was a regular daily thing
that represented the nation of Israel as
a whole so in addition to that you could
bring an offering but that was the
purpose of the son offering was for the
nation of Israel well it was an
agricultural society and many people
back there had their own sheep and goats
and they would bring him up to Jerusalem
anyway hey I hope that helps a little
bit Carolyn we do have a lesson that
talks about the the temple and the sing
and the sanctuary services we'll be
happy to send you a free copy are you
thinking about the one God drew the
plans yeah that's well they yeah that's
dealing with the sanctuary the number to
call is eight hundred eight three five
six seven four seven that is the
resource phone number and if you'd like
to learn more about the sanctuary in the
sanctuary services and its significance
to the Heavenly Ministry of Jesus we'd
be happy to send you this study guide
called God drew the plants again that
number is 885 six seven four seven if
you have a Bible question our phone line
here to the studio is 800 four six three
seven two nine seven a next caller is
let's say we have Ronald listening in
Minnesota
Ronald welcome to the program yes Ronald
in Michigan Michigan all right
yeah it's revelation 3:9 and it's the
second line down which says they are
youth which say they are Jews and are
not but lie
those folks well I think he's talking
about people from the synagogue of
satan' as he calls it pastor Ross
where's the synagogue of satan' who are
they
well that's talking about people who
claim to be believers but they were
really serving the devil it's not that
there was a church where they sign on
the street somewhere John is speaking
there of an age in the church that they
went through where there was a lot of
false Christians they claimed to be
Christians but jesus said they're really
of the Church of Satan yes well you know
in the book of Revelation just jump in
here real quick it's interesting
revelation is a symbolic book and you
know talks about horses galloping in the
sky and alike but in the book of
Revelation you don't find Christian
mentioned there are two groups there are
Jews and they are Gentiles but if you
look at the description that makes up
the jewel what the Jew represents it
represents God's people as it talks
about coming from every nation the
gospel is to go to every nation kindred
tongue and people so in the book of
Revelation being a symbolic book you
have the Gentile and you have the Jew
now during this time period is referred
to in Revelation chapter 3 it's talking
about a time period in the Christian era
symbolically the Christians are referred
to as the Jews and then you have those
who are of the synagogue of satan' those
are those who claim to be Christians but
we're actually turning others over to
the persecuting powers of the day so I
know it's a little confusing when you
deal with revelation but the book is
filled with symbols and you've got to
compare Scripture with Scripture as you
begin to unfold these truth yeah 144,000
are all called Jews but we know that
it's not only Jews that are saved and
then the Bible tells us that he that is
Christ's he is Abraham's seed Paul said
he's not a Jew which is one outwardly so
you could be a Jew and believe in Jesus
and you're you're real fulfilled Jew if
you say you're Jewish but you deny God
well being Jewish just becomes like a
race or a nation then it's not no one is
saved by their
headaches that way thank you very much
Ronald we do have a book we'll send you
a free copy and it's called spiritual
Israel spiritual Israel I think you'll
enjoy reading that book the number to
call is 883 five six seven four seven
you can ask for the book called
spiritual Israel again that's eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven and if you have a Bible question a
phone line here to the studio is eight
hundred four six three seven two nine
seven we have Jeff who is listening from
Minnesota Jeff welcome to the program
hello hey Jeff you're on the air you
know I had a question came up with a
group of men and it's about salvation
and I was told that repentance wasn't
necessary for salvation but I believe it
is yeah go ahead I'm sorry oh and what
they brought up was like the Greek word
met nail which means change of mine and
they said that I think it brought up
acts 16:31 and it says believe in the
Lord Jesus and they were more focused
focused on believe and not repentance
and then seeing that there's nothing you
can do of your own power that repenting
won't save you but you must believe and
my understanding was you should believe
and then repent I mean repent of your
sins as forgiveness and then believe on
the Lord Jesus Christ yeah Jim I'm sorry
I was just gonna say if someone just
takes one verse and they don't read it
in the context of the other verses the
people who wrote Acts Luke he wrote the
book of Acts he also wrote the Gospel of
Luke and he's extremely clear that one
of the pertinent important steps of
salvation is repentance the very first
words that came out of Jesus mouth when
he started preaching was repent for the
kingdom of heaven is at hand John the
Baptist first words were repent when
after the Holy Spirit is poured out in
Acts chapter 2 and the people said what
must we do Peter said repent and
and so the believing and accepting all
comes after the repentance the sorrow
for sin see Jesus died for our sins
until it's the goodness of God that
leads us to repentance when we hear the
gospel about the goodness of God and the
sacrifice and the cross of Christ we are
sorry for our sins we repent we have a
change of mind and it grieves us that
we've heard God but there must be
repentance and confession the Bible is
very clear that if we confess and
forsake our sins we'll have mercy
the idea of just believing and not
having repentance well James tells us
the devil's believe in tremble it's not
that kind of belief that's just belief
that God exists it's the belief where
you believe the whole gospel including
the part of repentance and so any pastor
that is trying to remove the step of
repentance from conversion now there
that is I think really it's wicked
because you can't have the change of
heart without repentance hey thank you
very much Jeff I hope that helps a
little bit and I've got a message on
repentance at the amazing facts website
it's simply amazing facts to our ji
program is not over friends we're just
going to take a break for station
identification and come back to you in a
few moments we do still have some lines
open if you got a Bible question give us
a call now you will be in the queue for
the second half of the program 800
God says 804 637 297
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
amazing facts began in 1965 with a God
inspired concept
hello this is Joe Cruz on the amazing
facts broadcast facts which affect you
each radio broadcast would begin with an
amazing fact from science nature or
history followed by a Bible message that
touched the hearts of listeners from
every walk of life the program was an
instant success and the ministry soon
began expanding to include Bible lessons
in 1986 amazing facts added the medium
of television to its growing outreach
efforts offering soul-winning
evangelistic messages for viewers around
the world
in 1994 pastor Doug Batchelor assumed
leadership of the ministry adding the
Bible answers live call-in radio program
and new ministry TV programs began
airing on multiple networks around the
world for 50 years the driving vision of
amazing facts has been the bold
proclamation of the everlasting gospel
and with a team of evangelists circling
the globe and thousands of men and women
being trained through the amazing fact
center of evangelism program Affco the
ministry is helping God's church see a
rich harvest of souls amazing facts
God's message our mission
[Music]
every bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life so
what are you waiting for get the answers
you need for a fuller richer more
confident life you're listening to Bible
answers live we still have a few phone
lines open if you have a Bible related
question call us at one eight hundred
seven eight hundred four six three seven
two nine seven now let's join pastors
doug batchelor and john ross for more
Bible answers live second part if you've
got a question give us a call 800 god
says eight hundred four six three seven
two nine seven do you have a couple of
lines open and if you've joined us along
the way this is a live international
interactive Bible study we invite people
to call in we just like to hear people
tell us their Bible questions we do not
claim to have all the answers but we'll
search the word together 800 God says my
name is Doug Batchelor my name is John
Ross and we gonna go straight to the
phone lines we've got Eddie listening in
Virginia Eddie welcome to the program I
pastor Doug so my question is where the
Sabbath describes in Colossians 2:16
which says as it was a saddle of things
to come
well they're talking about the year of
Jubilee in Leviticus 25 and if so could
you give me verses that differentiate
the ceremonial status from the
foundation all right all that pastor
Ross looks and moves up and just for our
friends that are listening not
everyone's got a Bible open let me read
that to you if you go for instance -
I'll read Colossians chapter 2 verse 13
I'll start with and you being dead in
your sins and the uncircumcision of your
flesh he's quickened together with him
having forgiven all your trespasses
blotting out the handwriting notice that
handwriting of Ordinances that was
against us which was contrary to us and
took it out of the way nailing it to the
cross
having spoiled principalities and powers
he made a show of them openly triumphing
over them in it let no man therefore
judge you in meat or in drink or in
respect of a holiday or new moon or
Sabbath days which are shadows of things
to come but the bodies of Christ
now some people read this verse and it
says let no one judge you regarding
Sabbath days that are a shadow
well the Sabbath days is talking about
the annual Sabbath days that were
shadows of Christ's coming there's two
very distinct kinds of Sabbath's in the
Bible you get the sabbath of the ten
commandments that goes all the way back
to creation before there was sin before
there was a man well I guess there
wasn't man Adam and Eve but before there
was sin in the very beginning and it was
part of the Ten Commandments years after
the Ten Commandments God gave them
annual Sabbath days there were seven
Jewish feasts the New Testament
Christians that were mostly Jews some of
them were telling Gentile converts you
need to keep the law of Moses and the
annual Sabbath's Paul says don't let
anyone judge you regarding these
ordinances that were written by hand now
the Ten Commandments are written on
stone by God's finger it's not talking
about that but it says that the
ordinances were placed in a pocket
outside the ark as a witness against
them and that's why Paul says these were
the ones that were against us in
Colossians so if you have a few we got
Leviticus chapter 23 the entire chapter
is a description of these various
ceremonial feasts that occurred on
certain days of the calendar in addition
to the seventh day Sabbath which
occurred on every seventh day of the
week and these ceremonial Sabbath were
sometimes referred to as the Sabbath for
example I'm looking at Leviticus 23
verse 39 it says also on the fifteenth
day of the seventh month so that could
move throughout the days of the week
when you gather on the first fruit of
your land you shall keep the Feast of
the Lord for seven days on the first day
there shall be a Sabbath rest and on the
eighth day a Sabbath rest so this type
of Sabbath rest refer to you in the
feast could come in on Monday Tuesday
when any day of the week because what it
was attached
the 15th day of the seventh month under
yeah that's in addition to the
seventh-day Sabbath that never changed
yeah so one of these laws is written in
the Ten Commandments on stone that's the
seventh day Sabbath it's part of
everyone's weekly cycle then the others
were part of the ordinances now you
asked for another verse Eddie let me
give you a Deuteronomy for and I'll
start with verse 13 he declared unto you
his covenant which he commanded you to
perform even ten commandments okay so
there is a Ten Commandments everyone
knows about that spoken by God's voice
written by God's finger and then Moses
says and the LORD commanded me at that
time to teach you statutes and judgments
that's what the ordinances are that you
might do them in the land so you got two
separate laws there get the Ten
Commandments and the statutes and
judgments one written on stone one
written on paper once spoken by God once
spoken by Moses one put in the ark one
put outside the ark God made a real
clear distinction between the two so
Colossians Paul is talking about the
ceremonial Sabbath you know we have a
book called feast days the Sabbath's
that goes into this in more detail a lot
of Scripture and kind of deals with the
subject were happy to send this to you
Eddie or anybody who just calls and asks
the number is 883 five six seven four
seven you can ask for the book called
feast days and Sabbath's again the
number is 883 five six seven four seven
as for the book on feast days and
Sabbath's and we'll be happy to send it
to anybody who calls and asks or and go
to the amazing facts website just
amazing facts to RG be able to read the
book for free right there online all
right well thanks for calling any our
next caller is Jeff and he's listening
from New Mexico Jeff you're on Bible
answers live talk to you again sir I was
like sleeping like in my bed early this
morning and I was like thinking about
God and I wanted to reason out to him
and that brought a burst into my mind
about
when it was saying come let us reason
together in Isaiah yes and though your
sins are like red as crimson it can be
white as snow and then I asked myself
how can I recent to God I mean I can't
see him I mean usually when you listen
to somebody you wait for somebody to
respond to you but how can we get the
response from God if your is not Remus's
you can see him well you know we we do
talk to God of course in prayer and so
we can ask God questions and ask for
answers and and sometimes you have to
wait for the answer
you do have occasions in the Bible where
people like Moses and Abraham they
actually were in conversations with God
and reasoning with God you've got
Abraham arguing with God when God's on
his way to destroy Sodom and say no will
you destroy the righteous with the
wicked and you have Moses reasoning with
God and saying things like look take my
name out of the book but what about your
people and what will the Egyptians say
if you wipe them out and so you can
actually hear a dialogue God has no
problem of our communion with him in
prayer you may not hear an audible voice
but you keep reading the word and God
will speak to you and you say oh that's
what he's telling me God will speak to
you through your spirit through
Providence through other people through
his word and not in that order
but yep yeah you can already God my mind
is not about the Bible question it's
about personal sir like you know I mean
like I've been having hard time falling
asleep since I was young and I know that
if I been having enough sleep I could
have been a lot better you know I could
have been I could have accomplished a
lot of things I could have been much
better than I am right now right you
know it's it's a it's probably about
health you know I mean I can't sleep I'm
having hard time get but like I just
don't want to ask a doctor for some
sleeping pills because I don't want to
get a dick
do it well I tell you what let me share
something with you Jeff now this is a
Bible program but there are actually
some Bible principles and I'm not an
expert but you know in the Bible and
pastor Ross and I travel a lot and
especially when you're in another
country and at times on it it's hard to
go to sleep we understand but in the
Bible there's some tips one is if you
exercise it makes it easier to sleep the
Bible says the the sleep of the working
man or laboring man is sweet and so
that's one thing the other thing is if
you have a clear conscience David says
I'll lay me down and rest even though
there's a war going on because you will
keep me and you do not slumber or sleep
so having peace in your heart getting a
good work having a good diet so if
you're eating good food and then a lot
of people in America's struggle with
insomnia because of caffeine I don't
know if that's part of your life but
that has lingering effects and there's a
lot of people that are struggling and
taking sleep aids because of the
caffeine addiction you know there's
another thing we can do sometimes when I
have a hard time sleeping I have the
Bible in audio and I just turn that on I
actually have it on my phone and you
just listen to the Bible and as you're
listening to the words and the stories
you kind of doze off now I have to set a
timer on that otherwise I end up going
through like three books of the Bible by
the time I wake up in the morning it
just keeps going so you can't set a
timer but it's kind of nice to fall
asleep listening to the word these
people that do that quite a bit some
works really well yet if you get some of
my sermons people tell me that they
can't go to sleep they listen to my
sermons
thank you thank you appreciate your call
Mick Foley's Chris listening from
Florida Chris welcome to the program
Christian England Fruitland Park Florida
thank you okay we can now and your
question tonight yeah this is a
difficult verse let me read this for
people who are listening
he says here for it is impossible for
those who were once enlightened and have
tasted the heavenly gift and were made
partakers of the Holy Ghost and have
tasted the good word of God and the
powers of the world to come if they fall
away to renew them again to repentance
seeing they crucify to themselves the
Son of God afresh and put him to an open
shame
so is your question what does that mean
or does it mean it's impossible for a
person that was once a believer when
they backslide to be converted my
question is considered those enlightened
one of those people that were touched by
the Holy Spirit what well I'll give you
a couple of examples in the Bible
you've got Balaam who was a prophet of
God he tasted the Spirit of God he was
enlightened he even says in some of his
prophecies about you know the
relationship and the glory that he
experienced with God that's in the Book
of Numbers but he turned away because of
covetousness and because he would not
repent it was impossible to renew him to
repentance and save him
then you have Judas where do you find
Balaam pastor Ross is looking it up
right now
Balaam is mentioned in several chapters
I main stories in numbers I think he's
mentioned briefly in Deuteronomy numbers
22 okay
numbers 22 you can read that and then
you can read about Judas of course who
walk with Jesus he saw the miracles
Jesus you know poured his spirit on the
apostles and Judas would not give up his
greed and so if a person has received
all these blessings of God and the
communications from heaven and they
cling to their sin it's impossible to
renew them to repentance they've got to
humble themselves and turn from their
sin so what God God is not saying in
this verse is that when a person
backslides they can't come back because
the whole story of the prodigal son is
about a son who is in the father's house
but he comes to his senses he returns
home and he's
fully adopted back into the family so
God is not saying that you know once
you're a Christian if you backslide you
can't ever come back there's too many
other stories in the Bible let's say the
opposite but if a person is filled with
the Holy Spirit and they then turn to
their sin and they won't turn from that
sin there's nothing more God can give
them if they're rejecting the best that
God has what else is he gonna do okay so
I guess my question is what is left for
those all the way well if a person knows
that they're falling away and they want
to repent they can even ask God to
soften their hearts and help them repent
and God will do that sometimes we need
to pray that God will make us willing to
be made willing I mean even Peter denied
the Lord but he repented and and he was
restored so you know I've got a book
that I'll send you a free copy Chris
it's called beyond mercy and it deals
with what is the unpardonable sin
because that's really what we're talking
about here if you call the number Pastor
Ross is gonna give we'll send you a free
copy and this is a real book called
beyond mercy but it's also got a lot of
encouraging thoughts in there about
repentance the number to call is eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven you can ask for the book called
beyond mercy we'll send it to anybody
who calls and asks again that number is
885 six seven four seven we have scarp
listening from Wisconsin Scott welcome
to the program likewise thank you so
much my question is on a first Timothy
when Paul wrote the listings of an elder
and a deacon okay they both speak of
having their there of one wife okay now
personally I was married and divorced
before I was saved I was married after I
became saved and my wife had infidelity
and I wanted to work out the marriage
she decided not to so I'm single now but
because of my marriages am i
disqualified from being a deacon all
right well I will be
I'll tell you what I believe the verse
is talking about you as far as
qualifications to be a deacon or an
elder you know there's several
qualifications given in the past Ross
wears is it Titus also besides first
Timothy yes - there's a couple of places
where Paul goes through those criteria
when he says the husband of one wife
Paul was not saying that a person had to
be married to be an elder because Paul
was not married Paul was not saying that
a person could not have been remarried
and been an elder because if you are
remarried with biblical grounds Abraham
was remarried he would not qualify as an
elder that's kind of crazy to think that
according to that standard even Abraham
would not be qualified nor would David
be qualified to be an elder of course
David had too many wives he broke all
the rules but so they did have polygamy
though it wasn't as prominent during the
Roman time there was polygamy and he's
basically saying you can't have more
than one wife a number of the Romans had
a wife and then a concubine she didn't
have the status of a full wife and the
Greeks also had that and so Paul is
saying you can't have a concubine you
can't have multiple wives you have to
have one wife so he's dealing with the
God's original design in Genesis one man
one woman he's not saying that if your
wife dies and remarried you can't be an
elder because technically you've had two
wives now he's not saying that if you
get divorced for biblical reasons you
can't be an elder he's just talking
against polygamy in those verses in my
opinion now the chapters you referring
to he's first Timothy chapter 3 talks
about requirements to be an elder and
then also Titus chapter 1 verse 6 there
you have it and by the way Scott I have
a book I wrote that addresses some of
this and it's called marriage divorce
and remarriage I think based on what
you're sharing you would be blessed by
reading this and we will send you a free
copy if you call the resource line the
number to call is eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven you can
just ask for the book called marriage
divorce and remarriage we'll be able to
send it to anybody who calls and asks
our next call is Carol and she's
listening in Ohio Carol welcome
the program hello hi how are you doing
I'm doing good
there was a caller earlier that talked
about the holy spirit and from what you
said I have a question concerning when I
was just maybe seven or eight years old
I had an experience where for the first
time I saw a figure a popular figure
that had a lot of people assembled right
near them and this was like I think
around Easter or something and I knew
that it was wrong even though I had
never heard of this person I never knew
anything about you know it was a
religious figure and I didn't know
anything mostly at that age
yet I felt that it was wrong I just it
was like I had this dreaded feeling that
something was terribly wrong so how do
you want to frame this in a question
then does God give us something when
we're born I mean he creates us and are
we born with that instinct to know these
things
that's a good question the Holy Spirit
you know I that's a good question
I think there are some people that God
has blessed with a gift of you you know
we sometimes call it intuition spiritual
sensitivity I've just met people you
know we have different gifts of the
Spirit and when we're consecrated to God
those gifts become more vivid Joseph had
a gift for interpreting dreams now
Joseph said you know the credit goes to
God but Joseph always managed to
interpret every dream that was told to
him
Daniel had that gift of spiritual
sensitivity of being able to interpret
dreams which he did on two or three
occasions so you know I do think there's
some people that are more sensitive that
way that
have some of those spiritual gifts of
discernment is what I think it's called
and you know God God speaks to us in
different ways and it could be you know
you've you've been given a gift of
discernment in that category so that's
entirely possible
Carol and yeah we appreciate your we've
got a book that I think you'd appreciate
called life in the spirit that's pretty
much up the alley of your question life
in the spirit if you'd like we'll send
you a free copy the number two cold air
is 883 five six seven four seven you can
ask for the book called life in the
spirit and we'll be happy to send that
to you Carol or anybody wanting to learn
more about living in the spirit and
being guided by the spirit through the
word I next holy Zizek listening from
Virginia Isaac welcome to the program
well wait a minute I think Isaac is
getting ready to take the cold air at
least our screeners are working on that
we gonna go to let's see Connie in
Atlanta Georgia
Connie welcome to the program hi hi and
your question but I'm just started from
the beginning they had came in a band
then I can't kill Abel and then it says
in Genesis that God you know after he
led Cain know if anyone come to kill you
they will be punished seven times but
this is my question
how did Cain have a wife how did all of
this begin if there was only Adam and
Eve good question you know we get this
periodically as a just you know rational
people start reading through the Bible
says that God had Adam yeah I'd rather
Adam and Eve had Cain and the man table
and Cain kills Abel and then says Cain
took his wife and you wait what we're
cheating them from if you read on and
you get to Genesis five the Bible
sometimes backs up and gives the answers
and in Genesis 5 it says Adam and Eve
lived a long time and many others sons
and daughters besides Cain and Abel back
in the beginning it was not considered
forbidden to marry a sister or a cousin
Abraham maybe not yeah Abraham married
his half-sister Sarah and Abraham had
the same father yeah Jacob married his
first cousin
so Cain took one of his sisters you have
to think about it Adam and Eve had the
same mother and father too I mean God
made Adam and Eve but you need to call
him brother and sister if you want to do
but you know it was there's nothing
wrong when man's genes were perfectly
vital and pure there are no genetic
defects from a brother and a sister man
like it is yeah but now you'll have
weakened DNA from that and it sounds
like we got a beeper happening Connie
hopefully that helped a little bit and
we appreciate your question thank you
we've got Jerry listening in Oregon
Jerry welcome to the program I'm looking
at Leviticus Deuteronomy 23 chapter 2
which says no illegitimate person or
person of illegitimate birth shall enter
the Assembly of God even down the tenth
generation now quite frankly I don't
know much about anybody past my third
generation how did they keep track to
this from our perspective doesn't seem
quite fair either then while I was
waiting I also thought about the
scripture which says God does not hold
this the son responsible for the sins of
the father or something like that
could you comment on this yeah that a
really good question
first of all first part of your question
how did they keep track well when you
read in the book chronicles Matthew
chapter 1 Luke chapter 3 the Jews were
very fastidious about keeping
genealogical records and they've got the
records in Chronicles that go all the
way back to Adam
they've got all the father's and many
that are not mentioned in the story are
mentioned there secondly God felt
marriage was so sacred that nobody was
going to hold office in the congregation
of the Lord if they were illegitimate he
wanted them to have families he didn't
want like we've got today where all
these kids growing up without mother's
or Father's and then you do find
examples where though that was the law
God was very merciful with that law
because there was a judge in Israel by
the name of Jeff Thumb pretty sure was
jephta who was illegitimate and in spite
of that God allowed him to be a judge of
Israel and he was filled with the Holy
Spirit and God used him to get a victory
so sometimes God gave the ideal standard
there's also a law that said a Moabite
in the next verse on the ammonite I'm in
Deuteronomy 23 go to verse 3 an ammonite
or a Moabitess shall not enter the
congregation of the Lord even to the
tenth generation
well you look at King David's
grandmother or was a great grandmother
was a great grandmother Ruth was a
Moabite and she certainly did become
adopted into the nation of Israel and it
basically she forsook her Moabite gods
and worshiped the God of Israel so she
was embraced and David's only three
generations later and he becomes king so
you can see that you know God gave the
ideal there through Moses but he was
very merciful I hope that helps a little
bit Jerry they're they're giving us the
signal in the studio that we're kind of
running short on time pastor Ross I
don't think we'd be able to do people
justice if we took a another question
right now with about a minute left
listening friends the whole program is
not over yet we have some important
announcements we want to share with you
in just a moment we also want to remind
you that a lot of the resources that we
mentioned during the program you can
read them for free online we we send
them out if you like a hard copy we ask
you read it and share it with a friend
we want to get the truth out we do this
free because other people like you
listening say I like this program I know
they're self-supporting
want to keep them on the air you can
donate right online we're sure thankful
you can read the resources at the
amazing facts website we got a button
that says free library and there are
gobs and noodles there's a biblical term
for you of literature there go to
amazing facts dot o-r-g God willing
we're gonna look forward to studying his
word together again next week god bless
you
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
are you wondering what lies ahead in
human history landmarks of prophecy
offers clear answers to your most
pressing questions presented by pastor
Doug Batchelor landmarks of prophecy is
a video Bible study adventure designed
for today's audiences presenting the
landmark themes of the Bible in a
compelling way giving you knowledge to
face the future with confidence start
your epic Bible study adventure with
landmarks of prophecy today by calling
[Music]
877-709-7899 out top scholars and
theologians from around the country come
together to reveal the hidden history of
the book of Revelation with powerful
reenactments and incredible visual
effects this 95 minute masterpiece
brings to life the book of Revelation
like never before revelation is no
longer a mystery get your copy today
visit iTunes or AF bookstore calm
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word
visit our website at WWF act 0 RG and
sign up for our free Bible study course
and make sure to check out our online
bookstore at AF bookstore com which
offers thousands of inspiring books DVDs
and more to help you get the most out of
God's Word to take advantage of the
offers you've heard on this broadcast
call us at $887 RG did you enjoy this
program make sure to tell your family
and friends tune in next time for more
Bible answers live honest and accurate
answers to your Bible questions
[Music]